[Music]
hello guys today's
next lecture about games of the week
so for today's lecture i prepared two
games
that happened in november
2020 of course online because of the
pandemic unfortunately
almost no tournaments over the board so
chess world move on moved online
so i prepared two games that happened
lately in
between top grand masters the first game
was about prepared was against
between anish kiri and vladislav
artemyev in
chess.com speed 2020
championship and another one
i prepared is between
uh yanni pomeshi and vladimir kramnik
who
competed in resurvive memorial and also
affinities.com
both games were in mapping very very
interesting
a lot of theoretical value in both of
them
and i think that
you i i mean i hope that you guys enjoy
them
because personally i find them really
interesting that's why i decided to
bring them up today
so let's let's get started now we're
going to start with the game
between any giri and wells fargo
and this is one of the main one of the
games that they played in
um the speed um the speed chess
championship uh i they i
usually try to choose games uh from the
longer time segments
uh like five plus one or something
because you know usually when people
have more more time to think about
moves and so on the quality of the
play is higher um
i mean of course there are very strong
grandmasters top gram masters who
nonetheless their level will be high but
like if they have especially more time
you know
even i mean for everything for everyone
it applies that more time
higher quality so
anyway let's get started in the game i
have an e4 e5
i have three knight c6 uh d4 uh onion
gear decides to go for scotch
and it takes d4 knight takes d4 bishop
c5 and there are two other possibilities
main possibilities
which are knight f6 and queen f6 also
bishop b4 is possible
however uh knight f6 usually knight f6
here is considered as the
most solid or like objectively the best
approach here
as black however bishop c5 is also
also playable both bishop c5 knight f6
are
are good options for black so is queen
f6
to be honest be free this is modern uh
let's say approach that happened uh
i don't know when exactly the first time
but like i i know that
it became very popular in may 2000
may 2010 around like
[Music]
i remember i was i was playing 2013 in
2013 in the world cup against
alexander gristchuck and i
[Music]
lost first game with black pieces and i
had to win with white and i decided to
play something and pretty much never
played before i decided to play scotch
as white and i i saw that alexander
grisham was
playing at the time almost only bishop
c5
and i was hoping that you know he'll
play bishop c5 and i'll play knight b3
and we'll
enter this line which i thought
especially at the modern
at the time it was considered as you
know while he was having some
playable positions and good chances to
uh
to gain advantage however
used alexander played not f6 and i
didn't get anything
i was actually worse and i had my
chances but eventually when i'm
you know making a draw and i was
eliminated from eliminated from the
world cup
but okay anyway uh knight b3 bishop b6
uh knight c3 right now the main move is
knight f6 obviously however
there is a interesting sideline with d6
and i used to play this quite a lot with
fidel corrales jimenez uh online who
play i don't know how many games with
this line uh
like really lots of games on chess.com
and uh sometimes he was beating me
something
as soon as i was beating him usually i
feel like i feel like i had a
good results here so that's why i will
kept employing this line
and objectively it seems to me that
white
should be slightly better here however
black is pretty solid
and especially but you know white has to
play specifically one line right now
queen e2 is correct and now a5
the point is uh of a5 is to play a4 and
and change this knight from b3 and the
idea is that if white plays
a for themselves which is in this game
it is considered as somewhat inaccurate
for a simple reason that if white plays
a4 black
knight can jump to b4 and on the before
location 49 is very very strong versus
that just
plays there very well so
uh in this position also i want to point
out what happens after knight d5 which
is not what happened in the game
a4 knight xb6 takes b6 knight d2
and the knight f6 and despite the fact
that white
has bare pawn structure it doesn't
matter for the evaluation of this
position because this king is in the
center
and black very quickly plays short
castle d5 opens the center
and it develops a very strong initiative
there
so after f5 i need to play a4 which is
also in
an inaccuracy in my opinion what white
should do
what i think is to play bishop e3
and the idea of bishop e3 is to allow a4
but after which updates a6 it takes b3
simply move back bishop e3 after pawn
takes a2
rook takes a2 now rotates it to knight
xa2 and in general this is a pos this is
a position that
both sides should sort of aim for and
here it's why it's understandable why
black may want to go for this because
for one it simplifies the position
and on the on the queen side also white
cannot go along castle right now so all
kind of aggressive options from white
are you know not a thing anymore
and secondly it
sort of stabilizes the say the position
and finally
black has pretty simple development
right now two
essentially there are two choices knight
f6 and the castle or knight g7 castle
and then f5
knight f6 is usually made by connected
with d5
in general both approaches are possible
in my personal opinion it should be
slightly better here
because of the pair of bishops and if
white is in time on time
and white usually is on time to develop
you know the king side play queen d2
bishop e2 short castle
or bishop d3 or somewhere in the bishop
and goshar castle
while we have simply pair of bishops
advantage
which with pawns on both sides of the
board with open position
would certainly be
who said would certainly favor white
that's why i think
uh y should be slightly better here and
let's say energy seven
if not g7 let's say knight c3 queen d2
and five simply f3 and the
idea simply should be too short castle
and try to prove the pair of bishops
as you know advantages to you know uh
give some advantage to white
and yeah so i think but
you know it's not a lot but it is
something
is this no it's not a lot but it's
definitely something and this is
something
that white can hope for here of course
it's not
easy to prove it in normal game
especially in blitz as it was
so it's a it also is pretty good try for
for black to play
it'll get something that's not playable
and uh solid
as but as i say in general this is what
i should go for and
it's logical as well because it gives
advantage of pair of bishops
so in this position anish played a4 and
this is the move i think that after
which black
is simply doing well knight b4
and the right now i need to play with
bishop before one
very important detail to note is that
after bishop e3
uh black if black takes white cannot
take the quint on e3
and usually i should have mentioned
earlier but
idea of queen e2 here is to play with
bishop e3
and try to traverse bishops go long
castle and for instance united g7 let's
say bishop e3
take stakes let's say long castle
and this is a typical set up for uh for
white however if a4a5
is included and now knight b4 bishop e3
is not possible anymore so black
preserves this bishop on b6
which can be really annoying
yeah so bishop f4 right now i think a
good move for black
uh i mean happened in the game and right
now i think that
uh values of our team i don't know if
this was novelty or not maybe usually
four was already novelty i'm not exactly
sure but i really like that choice that
was played here queen f6 because
right now there is a certain problem
what to do this bishop
on f4 bishop e3 of course will run into
bishop take e3
and queen e3 is not possible and f takes
e3 definitely
white doesn't want to play bishop g3
would be a little bit passive
so uh you know there is some problem to
resolve at least
so seemingly one of the let's say
logical moves is to play let's say maybe
g3 maybe then bishop g2 go short castle
then
right because going long castle is
possible but then before
sometimes maybe not be something that
black
sorry white wants to do after g3 i
analyze it that is very interesting i
tried to play with g5 and i'm
pretty certain that this was still in um
preparation bishop e3
takes stakes right now of course queenie
freeze just knight xc2
so f takes e3 and right now queen e5
so and in this position even though it
seems like you know it's much better for
black because of the such a
terrible pawn structure for white it's
actually
completely unclear for example knight d4
knight f6
bishop g2 you know like if black can go
for example with long castle or
something then try to kick this queen
out of
e5 maybe f1 knight f5 also
is not guaranteed that you know this
pawn on e5 sorry upon uh the square on
e5 will
guarantee you know black's advantage
here
it could be also happened that it could
also happen that black king can be
in danger so uh
black has to be very careful here and i
thought that i would analyze
black should play bishop g4 right now
after queen f2 play with h5
and the idea about bishop g4 is to
prevent long castle
and the idea of h5 is to play after rook
f1 simply rook h6
or after the focus of h6 just to prevent
uh you know
i mean defend this knight on f6 and play
such position which
mapping is still totally unclear white
has what years of knight f5
uh knight to knight to b5 for instance
knight a6 has to go passively back
uh knight f3 is also possible queen c5
and this
basically very interesting position lots
of life
and i don't to be honest i have no idea
who's better
i seriously have no idea who is better
and because it's just so complicated
and unorthodox position that's difficult
to
to evaluate so
but what i can say for sure both sides
have its own chances
and it's from practical perspective it's
not easy to
play such a move like g bishop e3 and
then f takes e3 and try to prove
actually that i'm getting great heroes
white it's
very it's very difficult to play like
this so uh
honest for that reason i i i know it was
silly preparation or not
uh but he decided not to play g3 but he
played with bishop g3
alternative also would be to play queen
uh d2 as out under possibility the idea
is to play move
uh maybe
uh i mean just defend this non-bishop on
the four and not declare where to go
this
bishop yet and uh here
i would simply play as black bishop e6
and i think black is doing also great
here because after
let's say wrong castle 97
bishop g5 is not a possibility still
because pawn f2 is hanging and black
usually
wants to play moves like maybe knight
knight e to c6
or maybe to play through d5 or uh
simply like i don't know if even even
short castle it may sound even long
castle black it's huge choice
and i don't think white has any
advantage here to be honest
if any would be i would be pretty pretty
surprised
uh like let's say f3 knight ec6 would be
interesting
maybe short g5 simply queen g6 i don't
see any problems here for black
and one of the ideas for black would be
of course to play net xc2
early in the future because uh idea of
queen c29 before or heading design on b3
would definitely
be quite you know painful
for for for white to meet uh
so i think black is doing great here
so finally after queen f6 let's see what
happened in this game
the game happened bishop g3
and right now 97
and there was an alternative actually to
play with bishop e6
which is also very interesting and idea
is to play laughter don't cast a long
castle
to go to go this way and uh according to
the engines
uh what i analyzed with uh that is with
this is after long piece of music long
castle black is actually
better the to be honest i'm not totally
convinced
of that i don't see i don't see why
black would be still better here
but you know it's definitely going to
have to have something in mind
but let's say from human perspective i
really like 97.
i really like 97 because it's very
natural you know we want to go shortcuts
we don't we do we already want to go
long castle we got to go to
shore castle and if white goes long
castle then we try to
open the center or maybe attack on the
king queenside somehow
um that's why 97 i really like this move
right now uh long castle happened and
the
short castle and we got this position so
this is the critical position of this
game in my opinion after
in which
i think made a big mistake so um
[Music]
in general position is very dynamic
still like even though it seems like
it's not in reality it is because
kings are kings are on opposite side of
the board for this one thing and second
thing
um there are there's a potential
to create for both for white and attack
on the king side
and for black to create on a queen side
um and in such positions which are
indeed dynamic you do not have usually
time to play let's say slow
moves that slowly sort of like
improve your position you have to be
very concrete and dynamic
uh in whatever you are doing therefore i
would strongly
uh that i i would basically consider the
best move for white to be
move h4 right now immediately trying to
look for counterplay do not wait for
uh for black to do something just play
h4 play h5
go for you know counter play play
something very quick and
create some attack on the king side if
long as possible
for example bishop v6 h5
just uh try to you know look for counter
play bishop h4a could be sometimes a
threat
um it's still not afraid because queen
f4 will become will come with check
but you know maybe h6 could be an idea
like at least it does something on the
king's side right
so knight ec6
and right now there is possibility to
play move knight d5
so again very dynamic reacting
at the thread could be of course knight
c knight to c2 right sorry
knight takes c2 could be a threat and uh
let's say after let's take him b1 or
something
something like this could be a threat
right and kicking his queen out and
bishop on b3
takes the knight back and white
is lost because because just just lost
position right
so this could be a problem so therefore
we cannot just wait for whatever black
is doing we have to
react with white d5
which object z5 takes knight d4 you want
let's say most
active and logical moves knight xd4 we
should take d4
and bishop h4 so this would be probably
the most let's say aggressive hero
approach us wide
and this just shows that
very dynamic dynamic positions are
essentially required dynamic play
it can be you could usually you rarely
have time for
something if anything other than that
the same ship takes b2 king b1
queen e5 the problem is that queen c3
and idea of queen a3
would be beautiful if only another
photographer free and actually white is
winning
probably or at least yeah actually i
think about what is winning because
this con construction of those pieces
mostly these two uh bishop before bishop
between queen c3 doesn't quite hold
queen e5 right now rook here should be
winning somehow
for for white so queen e5 happened
i mean queen e5 is was my analysis and
simply f4 and
we would enter such end game where
indeed black has extra pawn
but the y has huge compensation have in
the form of you know
a better pawn structure and uh
initiative to start with because let's
say c3 let's say even this
uh rook takes a6 if rook takes a6 rook
simply can come to e1 and then invade
through the seventh rank
so if you take the pawn why would ever
black be better here with such pawns on
a6 and a5 even though there is an extra
point
i think position will be just around
equal but this is considered the best
play from both sides and
with such dynamic positions you'll never
know right
so that's why i think h4 would be a much
better track here for
for for anish to create
some counter counter play on the on the
king side
and ins as i said in such dynamic
positions you don't have time for moves
like in b1 or at least you rarely have
time for this because king b1
suddenly is way too slow it is
surprising but it is actually i think
way too slow
right now uh as far as i analyzed
uh our valencia artemis could have
gotten a huge advantage which is
surprising was move number 12 already
and he could have gotten a huge
advantage by playing with d5
and to me it's just really interesting
because d5
hits immediately in the center
and right now white doesn't have time
for counter play and it's black who did
it dictates who what's going on in this
in this game
let's say if the e takes d5 now bishop
f5 comes with tempe data on c2
knight a1 and simply rook f8 again queen
has to move somewhere
and right now for instance c6 attacking
uh i mean bringing you know changing the
center again
and considering you know how active
black pieces are
i think black is off on the verge of
winning pretty much
like let's say if dtx is knight xc6
knight d4 is coming okay c8 is coming
even 88 is coming like it's hard to come
up the
with anything that is not coming right
now uh
before with black for black so and if
rook eight fd6 is an e95
also i don't see pretty much next move
here for
uh for white it's very difficult to play
such position
loads of threats i only went simply
horrible
white black is simply much much better
so um yeah d5 would basically
in this position just
i don't know like would be huge would
lead to huge advantage for
for black instead uh in the game having
bishop e6
which is also which is which is an
inaccuracy however it's also a very
logical move
where you cannot it's hard to create
such move if okay it's easy to criticize
in the presence of
d5 but in the absence if there is if the
d5 idea wasn't present bishop pc would
be the second there's no that would be
the best move then
so because it's so natural uh ideas
knight ec6 and knight takes c2
maybe you prefer d5 a bunch of ideas a
really
no you know interesting uh and natural
way of playing
right now arnis plays h4 which is
correct finally he goes for
a counter play but he'll be better off
he would have been better off if he
played
h4 move earlier because you don't really
need move king b1
uh there is no need for this move so
knight ec6
uh right now happened in this game and
again this is a critical position and i
think
in this position uh
actually no uh yeah i think yeah in this
position
um
anish made a mistake or like at least in
some sort of in a
inaccuracy he was supposed to play move
knight d5 in my opinion
which uh sort of prevents knight xc2
simply
because right now after which of the x5
it takes d5 black has a choice very good
94 97
and both are possible
i feel like 97 is more accurate but you
know 97 is kind of passive
and 94 is seemingly more let's say
aggressive but knight d4 leads to
huge mess like completely
ridiculous and random position i'll talk
about in a moment i will just
show the first y97 i think is better 97
simply queen d2 and
if queen f5 if okay white can
say black can take on d5 but why do we
have always pair of bishops here
so i think that while we have always
enough compensation
if queen f5 simply bishops c4
uh queen d4 attacking is not bishop
queen e2
and uh something like this resulting in
approximately
equal end game y has pair of bishops but
you know right like the hg3 is a threat
um there is no really any reason why any
of the sites would be better here
uh i think positions around equal so
uh here this was what but like white
should have played
if knight d4 takes stakes
c3 would at least would like would have
led to total
mass like absolutely ridiculous position
after queen f5
king a1 rook fe-8 queen d2 seemingly
black is winning
while it's winning a piece but simply
bishop f6
is just totally unclear
because if if you take the nylon before
you open the a file
and the rook takes a4 will be a big
problem then
so for instance if c takes b4
a takes b4 bishop b5 simply c6 you
cannot take detective because queen
takes b5
just to show it quickly you cannot do
that as white
or black suddenly wins skin on a1 is
always
in like in danger so queen d3 let's say
now queen d7
kicking this uh bishop out of uh
c i mean b5 bishop c4 rook takes a four
game one d5
and i think this position is totally
unclear like
if i personally it feels to me like
black
is not risking much if anyone who's
taking risk right now is
white because of such weak king however
you know it's still a piece
and with correct play probably both
sides are holding
but i it's just kind of like a feeling
that it's easier to attack rather than
defend here
so uh this would lead to absolutely
total mess
uh but yeah and you nonetheless knight
d5 was the best try
was the best move in this moment uh
because um
this move that bishop e6 they spoiled
this advantage right now or like didn't
spoil advantage but like
spoil the chance of getting this huge
advantage with d5
but bishop e6 uh here position
pretty much unclear and that's that's
the result of let's say
you know of all this and accuracy of
brb6 is after 95 right now white can
uh complicate position a lot and uh
probably with correct play eventually
you know hold it
so but i'm just playing with h5 and
i don't know knight xc2 happened
i don't know if he missed that or maybe
he prepared something that
i don't know but knight x2 is very
strong move by artemis right now and
uh if of course queen or king takes do
the knight before and bishop
bishop plays b3 follows just to show it
quickly
uh night before and there is no way to
stop bishop take b3 next because queen
has to move
so black is just winning upon and to
have his wing position
so in this position uh again
i think only move was to move to play on
d5 and this move
sort of i've i don't still
think that it would hold the balance
because black is just like
black has just extra pawn but it will be
the best defense because after b95
bishop takes d5 takes
knight d4 it's all logical takes takes
queen c4
black has extra bone true but white has
pair of bishops
and there is no immediate at least
attacked on on
i mean for i mean for for black there's
no way for
black to attack immediately somehow and
after let's say rook e8 bishop d3 i
think that here
white will have some compensation still
objective
blocks should be better but it may not
be easy to
prove because pair of bishops is
really really strong
positional factor and in and in here
especially
it is uh very very important because
pawn on h5 already you know takes lots
of space on the king side and
potentially
there could be some attack on the king
side as well and also bishop on b6 right
now is a little bit
out of place because on it doesn't do
much it's well placed but like
it doesn't quite do much so we better
place let's see somewhere like i don't
know on the
uh maybe on f4 ideally so
yeah but anyway this this was supposed
to
uh let's say be played or like you know
this was the way to play
with white and i think what would be
doing quite well
however you know of course it's not easy
to face moves like knight take like
moves like knight takes c2 and right now
anish
unfortunately made a big mistake because
he played bishop h4 and after queen h6
uh he's simply much much worse possibly
putin just around
around lost because he played queen
takes c2 if knight d5
still maybe was the way to go but it's
already very dangerous because knight
takes me
knight to b4 uh g4 and right now
maybe this was at least try you know to
make things
more complicated because uh right now g5
i thought it was the best move which was
very difficult
but also f6 should be better but you
know at least this queen on h
is kind of like not great g5 objective
is
by far the strongest uh but you know
it's very difficult move to play as well
so from practical perspective
knight d5 again was the best but
objectively already it wasn't sufficient
instead i need to play queen take c2 and
after knight before 22 bishop xb3
queen h6 gtx h6 this end game is simply
lost for uh for white so
this game was very interesting from
positional it's very opening
point of view i want to quickly show how
the game proceeded because uh i there is
one particular moment in the end game
that i would like to show
but pretty much uh until the end
anushkiri didn't have much chances here
in this game against uh art and valencia
artemis because
uh artemis simply presents the great
technique here
and uh he didn't even for one second
for one move let his opponent out
so rook h3 happened
trying to go for rook g3 of course f5 uh
rook d2
rook e8 we should b5 c6 rook g6 bishop
c7
all moves are pretty you know natural uh
ftx e5 e4 i mean white black still has
huge advantage
uh i'm just winning pretty much because
as there is an extra pawn and diamond
before bishop on b3
are very very strong black controls the
center essentially
rook takes b7 okay bishop c2 simply
bishop d3
right now bishop comes to d3 which is
you know great square for this bishop
uh bishop d1 king h8 prophylaxis just in
any case make sure this king is safe it
doesn't run into any checks
rook h1 back bishop d4 rather right now
uh on f2 is hanging f3 has
had to be played but f3 allows e3 which
creates
past pawn which is basically simply
going forward
knight d2 bishop g7 all right bishop e1
rook b8 right now on the bishop of
desire long diagonal also
does lots of damage because pawn b2 is a
weakness
takes takes trying to deal with it with
bishop c3 but this
in on the other hand allows takes takes
takes and in this end game
uh black should be generally just
winning
because this past pawn on e3 and such
strong 9 on before
i will point out one more thing here
knight on before has been
sitting there okay maybe the other night
went through before but this before
squares was important to move number six
is number 35 and right now this is
still it's very important so that's why
i think a4 is a kind of like
inaccuracy big inaccuracy let me say in
in the opening is not a mistake
so right now uh i think that rook d8
would basically just
win the game nearly on the spot because
after rook d1 takes takes knight c2 and
94
uh wins the you know and white sorry
black plays e2 next
bishop c2 would run into e2 obviously so
what black one promotes and black wins
and if king b1 of course we can invade
with rook d2 or g1 and the
right now king simply goes ideally to
f2 and the game is pretty much decided
so yeah this was i think the simplest
valencia artemis played 92 probably both
players were
in time trouble this move number 35 uh
it was
it was blitz but so you know but but
anyways
it's still winning rookie one king f6
rook e8
and it's okay this rook is not as active
uh on
e8 as it would be on d2 but still
black's plan is very simple king comes
to simply
the proof that r squares to eventually
ideally have two
so bishop h7 king g5 obviously pawn goes
to e2
uh king f4 king g3 as the king comes to
f2 and right now king e3 would run into
knight c2
just to show it quickly and black wins
an exchange
and if king d3 c5 it doesn't change much
because king f2 is a huge threat we have
to go king e3 but this allows again
knight c2
and the game is pretty much deciding
this end game
the rest doesn't quite matter
so this is how the game ended anyway
this was
very important and uh from let's say
opening point of view this game for
scotch the
first coach for scotch in defense
or or whatever it's called uh variation
and uh i think well this overtime
showed very nice idea of this queen f6
and then 97 and
very flexible setup and showing that uh
you know white's id white's the wise
move a4
like i'll just show it again quickly
from the beginning
after a5 a4 is an inaccuracy to allow
the sign to
land on before because it's just really
really strong there
so uh this will be all for this game and
i prepared
one more which was the game between
ayani pominoshi and
vladimir kramnik this one by the way the
giri artemy was really long one
however uh nippomashi kramnik was not as
long one
not not as long as the pre this one
but nonetheless it was very interesting
and
lots of happy those things were
happening there but still shorter so
uh shorter but nice still
so let's have a look so next next uh
thing i'd like to discuss here is this
game
c4 e6
d5 fe3 knight f6 knight c3
bishop b7 and b3 should consolidation b2
this is the line in reti sort of ready
slash english slash delaying d4 systems
i don't know how to examine them
exactly um
where white yeah why why tries to very
quickly develop
some initiative on the uh on the king
side
and this is maybe so this may be
surprising because you know how can you
does develop in them
one of the most solid openings i will
say this setup of queen's gambit
declined with
four black like d5 e6 like bishop e7 if
six
how can you attack here on the king side
right it is seemingly
very uh unlikely because you know
it's just so solid but as we can see it
is still possible
so in the game having b6 uh city xd5
knight takes d5 and right now uh there
is
some theory here uh evol
around revolving around knight takes d5
is i think the main move right now
and kramnik actually had a game here in
i don't know when exactly
but few years ago against sergey
karjakin after it was happening
it takes d5 i think queen c2 was in this
game
c5 d4 knight c6 uh bishop e2 bishop e6
very nice setup for black
uh shore castle rook c8 detects c5 beat
xc5
group ac1 queen b6 which one will get d8
very healthy setup from both sides
positions around equal
and i'm pretty sure if he aimed
something similar in this game as well
i don't think black is any worse here is
the the uh even though he lost the game
as far as i know but the position is
pretty uh pretty balanced and
no any reason to worry here for for
black
so uh this is what kind of like it's the
main theoretics d5 it takes d5 and then
plays c5
uh bishop e69 c6 and so on
however yanni prominently who is
well known for his uh great attacking
skills
uh play move h4 so this is
a typical let's say for this line this
modern let's say approach here with h4
idea is to basically play
queen c2 or queen b1 play knight g5 and
sort of attack on the on the on the king
side
and this is very interesting uh because
you know
if black does something you know slow or
something
than something like inaccurate this
attack can be really powerful
however kramnik in this game
demonstrated that there is not
much i mean if you know what to do here
with black there is no reason to worry
about this attack
and you can have a really really really
good game so i would like to show his
approach
uh bishop a6 very good movie mapping
idea of this move is simply trade light
square bishops
and potentially invade on with the
knight or the queen on d3 square
and if white doesn't allow that then
plays d4 then there is no attack because
this bishop on this long diagonal would
be close
in the event of d4 this bishop would be
you know pretty much locked on this
diagonal
because pawn will be on d4 that's why we
want to develop
we want to traverse bishops light square
bishops try to get to d3 and provoke
move d4
as uh as black
so uh in the game having bishop e2 and i
think that in this position queen b1 was
very interesting try for
for a while maybe i'm by the way i'm not
sure whether this is all theory
uh i think h4 was one of the you know
rare moves maybe
the maybe very few games like this which
are basically also i don't know
but quimby one i think is already a
novelty and the idea of queen b1
is again just plain knight g5 and sort
of to start to develop
the develop the attack on the on the
king side weaken the king side
putting more pieces there and
potentially just try to
checkmate black's king so
after queen b1 uh for instance right now
bishop takes the one king days of one
and before
seemingly is logical but y can play
simply with king e2
and with king e2 white controls the d3
square we don't have
to play d4 anymore and there is no way
how you can with white sorry with black
to
get to d3 very i mean soon or in general
to white king
and white can play move like queen e4
could be a possibility maybe not g5
maybe not e4 then something some the
other knight to g5
bunch of possibilities for for white and
i think what should be slightly better
here
or at least have great attacking
attacking prospects
therefore i was thinking when i've been
at xc3 trying to simplify the position
would be the good approach
after it takes takes uh simply playing
97. also it was possible with bishop f1
not the king of one night knight xc3
but yeah makes no known difference don't
order
here however what i'm trying to say is
that in this position of 1097 black
tries to in general
bring this knight to f6
or maybe play bishop f6 first and then
bring the knight to f6
and you know make this make sure that
king side is
uh safe and solid probably
you know black is doing well here
however it is a little bit scary to
play with black like this uh so i think
this queen one would be a pretty good
try let's say maybe in the future games
uh if anyone plays white i was expecting
some queen b1 because it's very typical
let's say knight g5
g6 and either free back
and for instance bishop f6
you know it's it should be around equal
but like it's never
kind of like you know the such position
for instance this h5 idea still looms
and you never want to play h5 yourself
um it could potentially get worse for
uh for black also the idea also for
white
would be to maybe switch to let's say
queenside play there's also this
flexibility
with let's say rook ac one and queen c6
trying to blockade on the c file
um possible like they're
i probably i prefer white however black
should be in general fine
um so yeah this queen will be very
interesting
to see what water fury you know uh
unfolds in the next few in the next
games
because uh yanni promised to play bishop
e2
after c5 you play queen b1 which is you
know essentially the same idea but why
would you play bishop e2
if you can just play queen one uh
instantly
that's why i think this was a little bit
inaccurate
uh and right now uh knight b4 happened
which is a very strong move idea is
again to play with bishop d3
or knight d3 usually bishop d3 and
you know try to invade on this d3 square
if such knight would be planted on such
you know
square as d3 black certainly would have
a
big advantage so uh in this position
white faces some choice and
i think here is where uh yanni pomeshi
went wrong
because right now he played with bishop
takes a6 and you know he played bishop
e2 then you play bishop takes a6
it kind of doesn't kind of sync together
in my opinion
uh because like why would you play the
bishop e2
at first place i know this was you know
i think blitz or something
but still like uh just i'm just trying
to analyze
uh you know
visual basic is kind of like it's not a
good follow-up towards you know relative
to
you know bishop takes uh a6 you would
rather
wait for black to take on e2 and then
keep taking the king
and try to uh you know not to give
any tempest to black so therefore i was
thinking
that white should try move like
uh one idea with a head was basically
play queen e4
and this is possible however in my
opinion
uh after queen d6 black should be doing
quite well because the points after
queen takes a8
knight from a to c6 simply uh traps the
queen
so you cannot do that after bishop g5
black will have possibility of playing
knight bishop d3
covering the on h7 and here black
would be here analyze further some lines
and black is doing well so queen e4 uh
just for sure for instance bishop dayz
frequent xd3 if queen a8
knight c6 queen b7 black has enough
compensation by
uh taking and rook d8 basically
white king is right now in big danger
even though it has extra rook
black is not risking here pretty much
anything and only
you know has to be careful not to not to
you know
lose and also ideas knight c2 you know
it's
he's a really really big threat on top
of that queen takes two is a big threat
so black has to be i mean white has to
be really careful right now
so uh this would this so therefore queen
e4 was my initial intention but
then i then i realized that queen d6 and
ig5 doesn't quite work
so uh having said that i
thought that okay if this idea of queen
i mean the idea of implanting something
on d3 like bishop d3 or knight d3 is so
so strong here in this position maybe
why should try to prevent this
and the way to do it i was thinking
maybe is to play with knight b5 which is
a little
a little bit weird it may seem at first
because like it's going towards the
queen siren to
the king side trying to attack but if we
look at this from kind of like
other person another perspective it
stops black's counter play
i mean around knight d3 and d3 square in
general
so i think that position after 95 will
be totally unclear
let's say queen d7 knight d5 and let's
say
queen b7 would sort of make sense
but then simply a3 knight d5 h5
i have no idea what's going on it's i
mean technically anything can happen
black can play move like 97 or something
while i can maybe
you know consider h6 at some point this
king on the g8 does not feel really
feeling
really safe in my opinion so
i think that this was supposed to be
i mean this was probably the best way to
play with white
playing knight b5 which sort of prevents
the bishop trait
which is very important and prevents
black from getting to d3 square and both
things are accomplished
then white can consider or can focus on
attacking on the king side
or at least developing some initiative
there which
i'm not still saying that you know it's
to 100 percent uh
sound or you know it works it really
gives a big advantage
but definitely it is possible and a blog
would definitely face some practical
problems so
and if quick c8 something similar can
happen let's say right now bishop d3
and the idea is to put pressure on the
on the
h7 pawn and the thing is that g6 already
loses due to h5
of course and right now you know the g6
something will be sacrificing disease
with some mating attack
so this is not possible f5 weakens the
a5 square let's say what can block and
play again h5
of course position is still unclear
totally unclear i have no idea
i'm not i'm not girl i'm not saying that
black white is much better or something
like this
even if it may be slightly but this is
like you know very dynamic and
unbalanced position
let's say black can play with knight d7
or knight c6 all sort of moves
which lead to lots of
lots of fight pretty much so um
i don't really i mean this pro this is
what i'm trying to say that this was the
way to go as
as white and h6 of course let's say
would run to maybe g4
like i'm just going all in pretty much
on the king side but
uh it has is just justification in logic
obviously because
this is what the point of queen b1 we
should defeat all those moves to attack
so
it's logical to continue with g4 so
therefore
in this position after univ4 i think the
best move was to move to play knight b5
and this actually reminds me right now
it's very often in queens queen's
indian defense with g3 which is totally
different obviously but like there are
ideas of knight b5 which has solely you
know prophylactical
uh idea which is you know with the
purpose of this knight b5 move is still
solid prophylactical
also in catalan also uh knight b5
sometimes happens whenever about
blackberry c5 and has
only it's only let's say ideas you know
go for prophylactics right now
prophylaxis
so uh here is the exactly same thing
so i think it's a good idea to remember
instead any partnership in play bishop
takes a6 which i think is a mistake
because
right now it helps even though the edge
of the board but still develops this
knight
king e2 makes sort of like logical sense
but you know
uh to play king e2 and not allow uh
knight d3 or queen d3
but right now uh after f5
suddenly there is no any attack for for
white
there is no clear follow up here what to
do here with with white like this king
is in the center
f5 cuts the queen from b1 you know g5 is
never possible again uh
i think this is just suddenly a really
really
bad position strategically for white
maybe it's not still much worse but
definitely is unpleasant
and because this f5 move cuts off any
activity on the king side
it simply leaves white with uh
i don't know like king in the center
unjustified queen on b1 and pawn h4
which don't make sense together if there
is no attack on the king's side and f5
simply you know
pre just shuts down all the activity
there so i think right after five per
first removed by vladimir kramnik
um the black is simply in charge here
don't seem to be better
uh in the game i happened a3 knight c6
and probably janine
she realized that something's wrong here
because he can attack
easily and let's say
if h5 okay just knight c7 bring my
knight to the center play queen seven
rook d8 okay h6 just g6 we can play
no any follow-up whatsoever here for y
with this attack and king only two is
definitely a problem and
strategically i think black is simply
better so assuming that he realized all
of that i think that
that's the reason why what tempted him
to play with g4
but g4 is a little bit too much
unfortunately
uh g4 unfortunately for ryan
she simply loses but loses in a very
beautiful way and that's
that's why that's the main reason why i
want to show this game because
it qualifies as a game of the week
pretty much because of the
beauty that followed right now right now
after g4 in mapping
so takes knight g5 so this is the
typical setup for uh for white play this
puts this queen on the same on c2 and b1
keep zerg on h1 play h4 knight g5 and
shoot hg5 ag attack on h7 so this is
typical
but right now uh vladimir kramnik played
extremely strong rook f2 which is uh
simply crushing it's totally crushing
right now
uh white king is simply getting
mated or nearly mated
let's see how the game followed
king takes f2 also by the way bishop
takes g5 and rook f2 will
lead to similar outcome uh it would also
work
uh but rook texas 2 is i think just
much simpler because queen takes the two
and you know we keep more pieces on the
board so let's see if king goes to g3 or
something we can consider let's say
playing
bishop d6 as in this line which is 92 or
f8 if king g3 bishop d6 is additional
opportunity a possibility here for
for black and essentially the game is
just ends with the checkmate
king g4 queen e2 right the free by the
way this is not what's in the north
node this is not what happened in the
game but uh one of the variations
but anyway i'm going to show such a
nice mate with knight on e7
the game happened king g1 but right now
simply bishop to hd5
and any person played
rook h2 and because after h3 g5
again might would make a checkmate will
follow by queen dayz free king
g2 queen f3 another check and finally
rule comes to the joint that comes to
join the attack and the
king is basically checkmated on d2 in
the following line
and that's checkmate right so uh
basically this i after rook takes f2
come back to this position
black's attack is simply irresistible
black is much faster to
deliver the m8 essentially uh king f2
queen d2
queen g1 once again and right now uh
rook h2 will happen in the game
but uh queen e3 king h1 bishop f4
even though white has extra exchange uh
it's not even though there is exchange
for white
uh it's not is like black has like how
many points actually four pawns right
four pawns for for this exchange and
white's kick is totally
destroyed black is totally winning right
now
94 happened queen f3 ruby g2 simply
queen h3
bishop e3 continue with the attack
g3 for
just you know just just winning black is
simply crushing here
and uh very nice very nice way to
convert or twins with black bishop f2
king f1
rook c8 just defend this knight on d4
on this song c6 brings bishop to d4
knight to d4
and finally trading queens and here was
when janipumashi resigned
so yeah this is how the game ended
anyway it was very it was very
interesting game in my opinion
uh again from theoretical point of view
like the the idea of h4 queen b1 or in
general ideas with screen b1 or also
then knight b5 turn trying to
not to allow traverse bishops i think
it's really
good to know such ideas and especially
if you if you play such openings so
[Music]
also then from black's perspective the
idea of f5 to shut down totally
like all activewise activity i'll just
bring it up again
with a five here this move f5
is just shutting down everything is also
very important idea to know
so yeah i think it was a very nice game
to show and i found it very interesting
for say from opening point of view but
also
because of the you know further let's
say understanding about this middle game
that this position is already really
dangerous and unpleasant for black
i'm sorry for white and that's the
reason why you know
when it was she decided to play move
like g4 which is losing
true but you know on the other hand
alternatives were not pleasing as well
so yeah uh just to sum it up uh both
games
i think were very interesting
i'm not sure which one was more
interesting i think both were equally uh
you know um i mean lots of
in both of them lots of things were
happening and
i tried to
explain in the best way i can what was
happening
in both of them um
in general again bringing back
again this game of anus versus uh
artemia a
vessel artemis this knight on b4 is very
powerful
so uh you know after a4 knight before
design before was becoming very powerful
um
so probably just better to go for a
bishop and
a pair of bishops after we should be
free and this game this again these
ideas of queen b1
and knight b5 and so on also are very
important to know
so both of them have lots of uh
theoretical value
that i hope you can guys learn for your
future
encounters and and games so
that's all from me for today i think and
i'll see you guys
next time
[Music]
you